[Musique]
bonjour à tous on se retrouve pour un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 dossiers pour
cette édition consacrée à la coupe du
monde en russie nous sommes dans le
temple du football français le centre
technique national de clairefontaine
[Musique]
somme
et
attention là
les élèves sont
clairefontaine ses 56 hectares neuf
terrains de football et cette résidence
d'hébergement
c'est ici dans le sud divine que les
français se préparent à la coupe du
monde mais vous allez voir dans cette
édition que l'équipe de france
s'entraîner au départ à jouy en josas
nous irons aussi à la rencontre des
supporters français et portugais de
saint quentin en yvelines
mais commençons d'abord avec cette
question quelles sont les retombées
économiques et sportives de la coupe du
monde
les réponses avec ce reportage de
michael et demi d'euros la carte bleue
n'a jamais aussi bien porté son nom ce
mois de juin lunettes de soleil t-shirt
claquettes les produits dérivés aux
couleurs de l'équipe de france s'arrache
dans les boutiques yvelinoise le
best-seller le maillot officiel
aujourd'hui on n'a même pas besoin de
faire de publicité quoi que ce soit mais
qui encore qu'il arrive la première
chose qui me demande d'aller demain une
équipe de france oui il est là n'est
pour vous donc demandé de donner connais
moins 10 de votre taille et puis je me
ferai un plaisir de les vouloir
récupérer au total 6000 euros de
produits qui de france ont été vendus en
une semaine dans ce magasin et le
parcours des bleus en aussi pour encore
booster les ventes jusqu'à épuiser les
stocks et relecture de soi qu'on n'est
jamais à l'abri de cela bien sûr après
je pense que dès que dès que la coupe du
monde va se lancer
on est aussi cadets par rapport aux
résultats de la france parce qu'aussi
jamais la france commence des matches de
préparation avec des scores fleuves ou
même des victoires
forcément ça va se sentir sur les ventes
un engouement qui devrait se propager
dans les bars dans ce pub installé
depuis 1998 voisins le bretonneux
les supporters étaient déjà présents ce
samedi 9 juin pour suivre le dernier
match amical contre les états unis
le taux de remplissage devrait encore
augmenter pour les premiers matches
officiels de la coupe du monde
c'est simple sur une soirée où il ya
l'équipe de france qu'ils ont
moi j'ai comme j'ai dit c'est à milliers
on sait pas trop mais quand ces amateurs
trans et
100 % de remplissage donc
l'établissement est au complet et il
faut réserver pour avoir de la place
quoi pour boire un verre c'est debout et
pour manger ouais faut réserver à
l'avancé puis des places assises valent
cher on va dire au delà du cadre
commercial sur les terrains la coupe du
monde est aussi un moyen d'attirer de
nouveaux licenciés dans les yvelines on
a observé une hausse de 18 % de joueurs
après le dernier mondial au brésil
un phénomène que le président d'honneur
de l'étoile sportive de tram mustapha
larbaoui connaît bien depuis son arrivée
au club en 2003 il ya une telle
concentration de match une telle
concentration d'image une telle
concentration de deux stars finalement
c'est c'est notre festival de cannes
tous les quatre ans et puis les faits
encore une fois nation donc la france en
particulier
forcément forcément oui il ya il ya cet
engagement particulier
aujourd'hui le département compte 39
1817 licencié ce chiffre pourrait
exploser si la france remporte une
deuxième étoile le 15 juillet prochain
en russie
[Musique]
des autographes des photos des échanges
entre les joueurs et les supporters ils
étaient plus d'une centaine à venir
rencontrer les hommes de didier
deschamps à clairefontaine
l'accueil toujours
et puis on est on est là pour la france
un dernier entraînement ouvert au public
avant le départ pour la coupe du monde
en russie les bleues ont pu constater la
ferveur autour de l'équipe de france
passe voilà on est soutenus non on est
soutenus nous avons quoi voilà toujours
à plus de rencontrer les supporteurs on
passe un bon moment avec eux et ça me
permet de voir tout ce que tout le monde
qui est bien
[Musique]
pour mettre l'ambiance les bleus peuvent
compter sur les irrésistibles français
ce groupe de supporters créé en 2002
compte plus de 1000 adhérents parmi eux
ce couple de maurepas sylvain et
jennifer charron a pas la possibilité
d'aller en russie
donc on va leur montrer que nous mêmes
restant en france on va on est là et on
sera toujours derrière
quoi qu'il arrive c'est parcours même si
la ramène pas c'est pas l'an prochain
match on avait cru
jennifer et sylvain ont rejoint les
irrésistibles français pour l'ambiance
participation au match rencontre avec
les joueurs dédicaces des maillots de
nombreux souvenirs conservés on a
quelques autres graves dont sudo dimegio
ici ou de griezmann
ici le 12 juillet 98 c'était le plus
beau jour du foot français
vingt ans après ce titre ils attendent
une performance des hommes de didier
deschamps durant ce mondial avec
beaucoup d'émotion stressant énormément
stressant ça combine voilà comme chaque
coupe du monde chaque coupe d'europe on
aimerait la voir au plus haut au plus
haut comme en 98 euros vivre ces
expériences là c'est c'est magnifique et
c'est pour ça on se bat pour ça le foot
nous donne tellement de joie que ça
vienne là une passion autour de ce sport
vécu en couple jennifer et sylvain reste
en france mais leur coeur bat pour les
bleus en russie on va la gagner j'ai
droit
[Musique]
la star de cette maison plaisir ouah
c'est lui cristiano ronaldo tom et
williams 8 et 11 ans deux frères
d'origine portugaise ont de grands fans
de l'attaquant lisboète et de son équipe
nationale
las ses crampons clavet l'année dernière
là c'est quand ils tirent des coups
francs et cher font là quand il m'a des
accélérations avec la balle est là qu un
dribble la scène les actualités c'est ça
au ballon d'or qu'il a gagné cette année
pour ressembler aux portuaires
la passion ne s'arrête pas qu'aux
posters et olives les deux jeunes
passent également près d'une heure par
jour à regarder des vidéos des exploits
du portugal et de leur idole
et quand ils allument la console de jeu
le portugal est évidemment leur premier
choix
est-ce qu'ils sont forts et ahonado
place café thé grosse frappe est cadrée
il fait une terrible très vite pendant
la coupe du monde en russie les deux
frères ont fait leur choix ils
supporteront l'équipe nationale
portugaise une décision qui ravit leur
mère je suis contente parce que c'est
vrai que moi c'est mes origines et je
trouve ça bien que les enfants s'en
rappelle est en tout cas enfin le
supporte le portugal dans tout parce que
c'est dans le foot mais c'est aussi
aussi pour plein d'autres choses ils
veulent tout le temps les lab en
vacances et adorent ils veulent y vivre
sur les terrains de football yvelinois
les coéquipiers de cristiano ronaldo ont
également des supporters depuis sa
création en 1972 le club des portugais
de plaisir vibre au rythme des exploits
des lusitaniens et non de l'équipe de
france y en a certains qui sont pour les
deux moi je suis pour les deux j'habite
en france et voilà
notre famille portugaise on a dû
supporter qg on sera toujours toujours
derrière le portugal quoi c'est comme la
plupart des personnes qu'ils ont double
nationalité on a grandi ici
nos parents sont portugais ont fait nos
vacances au portugal donc voilà c'est le
portugal a des qui a marqué le portugal
à leur tour pour vivre cette coupe du
monde le club a prévu d'organiser des
repas devant la télévision les soirs de
matches du portugal mais ils ne
devraient pas être les seuls à suivre
les rencontres dans le secteur très
grosse communauté surtout un plaisir les
clés et villepreux
il ya une grosse communauté portugaise
donc je pense que l'éveil des matches
tous les sens des mots le sait et moi
tout ça ou dans les cafés ou chez
d'autres regarder les matchs aura plus
personne doha avec plus de 4000
habitants d'origine portugaise dans les
yvelines le département sera forcément
partagé entre le bleu et le vert et
rouge pendant cette coupe du monde
[Musique]
jouy-en-josas à l'ouest de paris le lieu
traditionnel de rassemblement de
l'équipe de france avant ses rendez vous
importants des rendez vous importants
comme l'euro 84 les hommes du
sélectionneur michel hidalgo ont
construit leur victoire européenne sur
deux terrains à jouy en josas au sein du
campus de l'école de commerce hec et sur
le stade municipal jean-claude hamon et
yves quignon deux anciens joueurs du
club local ont des souvenirs des
infrastructures c'est parce que ça fait
l'entraînement tout petit local arbitres
si les lions ont changé aujourd'hui les
souvenirs restent intactes ex dirigeants
de l'ue est juillet en josas gens selon
miani à conserver des photos des joueurs
de l'époque
alors ça c'est des photos de l'équipe de
france didier six sa tignasse michel
platini
accor 6
rocheteau les stars de l'époque janvion
tigana lors d'une interview que j'avais
créé à l'hôtel val de bièvre j'avais les
cheveux un journal à l'époque pour le
club de foot local et j'avais demandé à
faire une interview novembre 1981 les
français jouent leur qualification à la
coupe du monde contre les pays-bas au
parc des princes boulanger à l'époque
jean claude hamon se souvient avoir reçu
une commande de la directrice de l'hôtel
où résidaient les bleus or les faits un
gâteau un petit peu rapidement parce
qu'elle est venue me voir le dimanche
pour lundi soir
tu t'es fermé le lundi mais bons rails
pour elle et puis ils ont gagné et en
cadeau elle en main le bateau était dans
l'équipe
oui les mecs en train de rigoler quoi
boire un coup avec la gâterie le gâteau
dans le parisien peut parier à l'époque
entre la fête va commencer à minuit elle
se terminera très tôt ce matin
ce n'est pas il est vrai toutes les
nuits concept la qualification il y
avait du monde et puis juste les très
bons enfants quoi surtout c'était les
gens ils rentraient exactement à partir
de 1988 l'équipe de france s'installe à
clairefontaine la commune devient alors
le centre technique national du football
français à jouy en josas le football
continue de faire vibrer les amateurs du
ballon rond
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 dossier spécial
coupe du monde de football merci nous
avoir suivis si vous souhaitez revoir
cette émission en replay rendez vous sur
notre site internet tv 78 ou d'autres
applications mobiles à bientôt pour
l'ouverture d'un nouveau dossier
[Musique]